every honestly held opinion deserves to
be heard but what Alex Jones was doing
was spewing deliberate vile lies to make
himself rich and he was using the
families of Sandy Hook grieving the
deaths of their murdered children to
make himself rich and he didn't care
about the impact of his lies on their
lives he didn't care that their lives
themselves became threatened by complete
morons who believed the nonsense that he
was spewing
well finally
it's caught up with him and families
sued Alex Jones and as a result
a billion dollars was awarded in Damages
yesterday one of the highest defamation
payouts in history
well I want to start by talking to the
retired professional wrestler and former
governor of Minnesota Jesse Ventura but
before I get to him I'm going to talk to
Nicole Hockley who lost her six-year-old
son Dylan in the Sandy Hook massacre and
she joins me now Nicole thank you so
much for joining me I thought of you uh
very
hard yesterday and all the families
having covered this appalling atrocity
that befell you all when I was at CNN to
see at least some justice being served
to this vile man Alex Jones for
perpetrating Wicked lies which
compounded your grief I guess it was
satisfying although his response of
course was to be completely insensitive
once again
what was your reaction when you heard
that this huge payout of Damages was
being made against him what was your
what was your response
my initial reaction was just to be
absolutely overwhelmed when the very
first amount of the of award against one
of the plaintiffs was being mentioned
and hearing that first number come out
and realizing that this was really a
very historic moment and the jury had
not only listened to us and really hurt
us they were sending a message you don't
get that kind of award without really
saying this is important and this is how
we're going to stop this spread of
disinformation and have people
understand that there are consequences
for your actions so I was overwhelmed by
a verdict that was significantly larger
than I could have thought about in my
wildest dreams but it was a message and
I and I think it's being heard
for people who think this is about free
speech and he should be allowed to say
what he likes and this is ridiculously
over the top payout I want you to paint
a picture of what it's been like for you
families from Sandy Hook to be on the
receiving end of this continual tirade
of lies and the Damage it's done to the
way that you can conduct your lives
yourselves
you know that's a good question and
because we kept so much of this private
from the public I've had a lot of people
reaching out over the last few weeks
saying I just didn't know I had no idea
that it was that bad I mean when you
think about for 10 years and this isn't
just something I mean he did his first
broadcast saying that he thought this
was a false flag
when I was still in the firehouse and I
didn't even know if my child was alive
or dead yet he started off within two
and a half hours of the shooting and has
kept putting out video after video for
year after year after year and calling
us all crisis actors calling our
children you know either that they were
never they were never killed or they
were never alive in the first place that
were traders that were were treasonous
and that were government chills it's
been very difficult it's been easy to
turn off some of it but some of these
people have been incredibly dangerous
and when he says when he when he Stokes
this anger in his base this fear and
then incites them to action by saying
you know we need to investigate this you
need to look into this more they come at
us so part of it's just social media
comments which can be damaging it's
defaming it's hurting your reputation
people I don't know if I'm walking
around who thinks I'm real and who
thinks I'm an actress
it's it's damaging to my son's memory in
terms of his life his short six-year-old
life it's damaging to my surviving son
because I don't know what he's going to
deal with going forward but it's also
scared The Living Daylights out of me I
sleep with weapons by my bedside I've
received death threats I've received
harassing calls and mail I've had people
send me pictures of dead children
because they say as a crisis actor you
have no idea what a dead child looks
like so let me send you this picture so
you can see it this is stuff that has
really not only just been distressing
it's disturbing and in terms of security
you know I'm just a mom I'm just trying
to look after my surviving Son run my
organization and make some good in the
world I didn't choose to be part of this
Alex Jones chose to tell lies
knowing that they were lies and
continuing to Harbor that lie and make
it happen for his own prophet and that's
what this trial has been about yeah I
completely agree and I think it's
utterly disgusting it's sickening even
as I hear you tell the story of what
you've had to endure the idea that you
lose your son and all these other
families lost their loved ones these
young kids who were at school supposedly
safe that you go through that and then
your misery and grief is is Multiplied
and compounded by this monster
deliberately lying just to make money I
I find and then imperiling your lives I
mean it's just it's so completely
sickening um Nicole you rewarded you and
uh and your husband in 155 million
dollars in Damages he's made it clear he
doesn't have the money he's not going to
pay it what is your message to Alex
Jones
this has never been about the money this
is about accountability this is about
showing up there's consequences and I
would hope that Alex Jones learns a you
lost okay that's the most important
thing here you lost truth is prevailing
here and you need to stop willingly
spreading false information just so you
can pedal beet juice and iodine tablets
it's it's absolutely ridiculous and to
all of his followers you need to know to
stop doing this as well don't just
believe what you hear on the Alex Jones
Show because it's not news it's not
journalism it's not fact checked it's
just his wild hypotheses so that you'll
send him money
um that's what needs to stop right now
Nicole I'm incredibly happy that you had
at least a moment yesterday you and the
other families where you held this
person to account and he will be held to
account for this money and it will
probably be bankrupt him and that is a
good thing it will stop him spreading
his vile lies and I thank you very much
for joining me like I say I remember it
very painfully covering Sandy Hook at
the time and speaking to you and some of
the other families it was one of the
most unbearable stories I've ever had to
cover and I can't even imagine what you
all went through and the fact this guy
made it worse I find repulsive so I'm
pleased that he's been held to account
and I thank you for joining me thank you
very much
thank you